a man fakes his own death and then
shocks his friends and family by turning
up at his own funeral what if Bobby Lee
faked his own death and then we're
having a funeral it's my turn to talk I
gotta make up some nice things to say
about him and then he comes walking in
the back hey everybody look I would beat
his ass of course I would be crying I
would hug him and then I would punch him
in the stomach and then we would do a
impromptu roast of him and everybody
that came up would get to slap him but
before they said something we would tie
into a chair and then we would walk by
him and just smack his ass pow
well glad we're already at a funeral
cause you about to die